[Music]
good morning everybody could boris
johnson's fate be decided within a
matter of a few days the pm is braced
for the publication of that report into
downing street parties during lockdown
which is expected any day now plus there
are claims that conservative party whips
blackmailed mps and allegations of
islamophobia within his government
here's our political correspondent rob
powell
westminster wakes up to a week that will
shape the future of boris johnson's
premiership while the publication of the
sue grey report into alleged government
parties during lockdown is not expected
today its arrival later this week will
leave a mark on downing street even if
the extent of its impact is as yet
uncertain it's clear that we need a
better relationship between number 10
and the
conservative parliamentary party and the
whips office that needs to work much
better than it has been doing there's an
impression of chaos at number 10.
it's been reported but not confirmed
that dominic cummings may be interviewed
by sue gray today the former number 10
adviser has accused the prime minister
of lying about what he knew of alleged
parties his evidence could prove crucial
to the inquiry's conclusions allies of
boris johnson believe there may be a way
through still if the su-gray report
leaves a degree of ambiguity over who is
responsible for any rule breaking rebel
mps also acknowledged that it may take a
categorical conclusion that the prime
minister knew in advance about parties
to really trigger a flood of
no-confidence letters
but number 10 is facing other challenges
tory mp nusrat ghani's accusation that
she was told she was sacked as a
minister because of her muslim faith
something categorically denied by the
government has led to calls for an
independent investigation
into both her case and broader
allegations within the party i think
what is needed is an outside independent
investigation into the conservative
party by the equality and human rights
commission exactly the same way as they
investigated labour party anti-semitism
boris johnson's government is still
being shaken by the scandals of recent
weeks it's that instability that means
many in his party now worry that even if
the prime minister survives the coming
days the body blows being inflicted may
eventually prove too much
raw pal sky news in westminster
so much to talk to the education
secretary nadeem so are we about this
morning good morning thank you for
joining us let's talk about nasgani to
start with
um how offended are you on behalf of
your colleague given what she says she's
been through
well nuzz is a valued colleague um i've
known her for a very long time
she's worked incredibly hard both as a
minister and as a backbencher she's made
a very serious allegation it was
the prime minister spoke to her last
night and said that the cabinet office
will investigate this and look at the
detail of this
she put out a statement last night
saying actually
and to be fair to that this could be
people who weren't even members of the
conservative party which is why we have
to get the bottom of this very quickly
and of course the chief whip has come
out and named himself as the individual
and i work with both colleagues and i
think it's important that um you know
someone like
a cabinet office senior civil servant
should look at this properly because
chief was also categorically denied this
i think it's important that well i'm not
going to impugn either colleague you
know we're we're one team we work well
together
as a team and that's what the nation's
expects and this is this is of course
and as i say this is a serious
uh allegation it you know it takes
someone a lot to um
you know
make such a a a claim i think it's a
point that um muslims allowed
the ability to put her
case forward put the evidence forward to
the cabinet office
why didn't anybody take what she had to
say seriously at the time i don't think
uh that's true i think that's what she
feels the the important thing is that um
well she's also said that that
you know she
spoke the prime minister of the prime
minister wrote her asked her to
put forward a a formal complaint she
didn't think that was the correct
procedure now the cabinet office can
look at this
uh properly
and i hope um be able to report back
swiftly when something like this happens
it's the job of the chief whip to put
their arms around an mp and protect them
while there is an inquiry going on
whatever given that this allegation is
by all intents and purposes he's out
here himself against the chief whip what
did the prime minister offer her instead
to protect her during that time well i
think what the premise has done and he
spoke to nazcani
last night is to offer her that
investigation from the cabinet office
which i think when you read her
statement again well he offered her two
years ago
at the time
for her to make a formal complaint
and use the party procedure uh i think
she also went before the
um islamophobia inquiry that professor
singh held for the party
um but look these are really
painful allegations um for anyone um of
luz's background uh uh to make i think
it's important that she gets
uh to be able to put her evidence
forward to understand why it's a party
issue i mean if if somebody actually
said that to her um it's islamophobic
well as i said
she needs to now be able to put her
evidence uh forward and i think the
right thing to do is to allow the
cabinet office to invest are you saying
it's her fault no not at all it didn't
come to light two years ago not at all
not at all i think
um as i said you know
i i don't have all the details she's uh
made an allegation which wasn't the
sunday papers and then of course
followed up with the statement the
important thing
is that you know what she's asked for is
what the prime minister um has now
spoken to and is delivering through
the cabinet office inquiry i wonder why
it's taking two years to get to this
position
well as i said i think the the yeah what
happened two years she was a vulnerable
woman she went to the prime minister she
said this is what's happened to me i've
been um sacked because i'm too muslim
basically um and it's taken two years
for it to come to light well and you
took it very seriously and he said if
you absolutely well this is a prime
minister who's uh said that muslim he
likened muslim women to uh letterboxes
and bank robbers well it's also the
prime minister that has you know
promoted
sahabi
anything other than uh the important
thing to remember is this is a prime
minister in in my view
who doesn't you know look at
your background or your religion or
anything else he looks at you your
ability
and uh you know whether you are capable
of doing a job and then uh actually
makes that decision at the same time
that's the prime minister muslim well
again i was going to say and it's the
same it's the prime minister who
actually asked a professor singh to
conduct uh an inquiry into islamophobia
the inquiry came back with some
recommendations which the party's
overhauling its systems
said about that i think the findings of
this report show clearly that the
conservative party is institutionally
racist
well it made a number of recommendations
uh for the party they also said that
that um
islamophobic was not widespread in any
way in the conservation process i don't
believe that i've been a member of the
party
i hope you know with all respect
apparently anyone else i've been a
member of the party since the late 80s
i've risen through the party i've been a
local councillor for three terms i've
been a
volunteer
uh in the voluntary party i've been a
member of parliament i have not actually
experienced any form of
women
muslim women are saying that they they
don't feel that that the party is is uh
treats women of color particularly
muslims appropriately
my my view is of course we can always do
better which is why we have the inquiry
which is why we're overhauling our
systems there is no place as i said in
my tweet over the weekend uh for any
form of racism of islamophobia
anti-semitism in our politics in our
party i take great pride in the work i'm
doing
with the education sector at
universities in terms of signing up to
the international definition of against
anti-semitism the work we're doing at
schools the work we're doing across
government i think that's important to
remember
but you know in a case where a colleague
a valued colleague um comes uh forward
and says look i i've you know heard this
or i i think you know
there are issues that i want uh aired
and dealt with it's only right that we
then deal with them what should happen
to mark spence in the meantime well i
think that mark spencer again i work
very closely with with mark has
categorically denied it and said this is
defamatory so i think it's only right
it's only faced one of our values you
remember when we talked about the sue
grey report before
um
taking five minutes yet to see well
it's one of our values values of
fairness and and people have to have a
fair hearing yeah uh and i'm not gonna
impugn the reputation of either
colleagues right that the cabinet office
looks at this okay william rag let's
talk about uh him chair of these
standards uh deputy chair of the
standards committee um he is seeing the
police today after allegations of
threats and blackmail
against mps
uh is whipping bullying
or is it bringing mps into line
so i've got good experience with this
not because i've been in the whips
office quite the country i've been a
backbencher for a very long time it's
taken me uh 11 years to uh get to
secretary of state i am the definition
of it is a marathon not a sprint in
politics and for seven eight years i was
a backbencher i've rebelled um the whips
and i've never experienced
the sort of um stuff that uh william rag
is describing at all i can tell you and
many colleagues actually over the
weekend came out with a number of
articles saying
they don't recognize this others
and and i think they have you know then
a responsibility to put that evidence
forward all i can say to you from my own
experience i haven't experienced any of
that and i've rebelled before but it
hasn't impacted anything to do with with
my work for my constituency all
government decisions you know there is
due process in government whether it's a
department of education or any other
department in housing you brought up the
department of education education
secretary because christian wakeford
said that he was told by the previous
education sector gavin williamson that
if he didn't come into line then they
would remove a school that was promised
in his constituency of berry
would you as education secretary have
the power to withdraw funding for a
school in an mp's constituency no
because we have due process in
government
that is absolutely not what happens
in the way we take it you don't believe
christine
christopher has just crossed the floor
and joined the labor doesn't mean he's a
liar no i'm not i'm not saying that i'm
just saying to you that he's made an
allegation against a colleague gavin
williamson um uh you know
clearly does doesn't a lot of
allegations against a lot of people
well no but all i'm saying to you is is
christian wakeford has chosen to leave
the conservative party and join the
labour party um all i would would
share with your viewers is that the way
we conduct ourselves
as a department of education we have due
process which we follow that particular
school is getting the funding that that
that it needs nothing has changed so you
know there is an inconsistency here um
in terms of what christian wakeford is
saying and what the reality is on the
ground okay um
talk to me about while we're on schools
are you pledging 9 000 air cleaning
units we are so you remember when i came
on the program
a few weeks ago we delivered 350 000 co2
monitors to schools last year to monitor
uh the air in the classrooms and the
data we got back which we're publishing
our survey on this today is that
actually the bulk so 90 for 95 percent
of uh classrooms were able to ventilate
and keep the air fresh from the data
we're getting from our co2 monitors that
was 25 million investment in co2
monitors then we modeled as to which
classrooms we thought may not be able to
do that easily and we thought i think
we're going to need about 8 000 air
purifiers yeah we think we need about 9
000 now and so actually
in terms of being stewards of public
money
rather than
you know
following what the labor party wants us
to do which is buy 350 000 air purifiers
at a massive cost to the
exchequer
we bought 8 000 actually last week we
got all the um
schools uh to make their um uh
allocation and we got to just over nine
just over eight thousand so we've gone
to nine thousand now we're delivering
air purifiers uh to help those schools
it's part of making sure that education
remains open i'm passionate about making
sure children
remain in school remain in education we
see all the evidence from the children
commissioner that that's really
important and that's why we're doing
including of course making sure that
that teachers get themselves tested
twice a week uh and of course
vaccination program which we just spoke
about okay and what is your advice to uh
school heads um who still want their
kids to wear masks even though it's not
compulsory anymore
so we we trust school heads and school
leaders to do the right thing i think
they would agree that masks can be a
challenge for learning for communication
in the classroom which is why i wanted
them not to last a day longer than
necessary when we saw the data
from the scientists that omicron was
plateauing and actually numbers were
beginning to drop and they told us that
we've reached the peak i moved very
quickly to say the guidance to where
mastering the carson can come away last
week the guidance for wearing masks will
fall away as part of plan b this week
um that's i think the the right thing to
do and of course
i speak the director of public health
have done a tremendous job working with
school heads to make sure that we get
this right in localities if there is a
an outbreak in a locality they can
reintroduce temporarily uh masks in
communal areas if they wanted to but
they work very closely with us and it's
a it's a strong relationship i have with
with the front line i'm very proud of
that yeah i didn't ask about downing
street parties once but i will be asking
later on in the week uh what does tl
stand for tory leader
t levels i'm going to make them as
famous as a-levels these are technical
they're a fusion between an
apprenticeship and an a-level and
actually they're a fantastic thing which
you're going to hear much more about
from me looking forward to it thank you
very much indeed thanks a lot education
secretary thank you
quick look at what the papers are doing
this morning telegraph daily telegraph i
should say says police officers guarding
downey street have been interviewed by
sue gray as part of her so-called
partygate investigation
her report is expected to be published
in the coming days
in what the i describes as a week of
reckoning for the prime minister
the time says boris johnson is
determined to fight on and still doesn't
believe he's broken any rules
and the guardian leads on the pm facing
calls to launch an investigation into
alleged islamophobia within the
conservative party following claims made
by the former minister nusrat ghani over
the weekend
meantime the united states has ordered
the families of its embassy staff to
leave ukraine russia insists that it has
no plans to invade despite moving a
hundred thousand troops to the border
the u.s government also warned its
citizens against travel to ukraine
because of reports it said that russia
is planning significant military action
against ukraine
late last night it also warned its
citizens against traveling to russia
because of the ongoing tensions with
ukraine saying there was potential for
harassment against u.s citizens
in the uk a foreign office spokesperson
said the safety and security of our
staff and british nationals is our top
priority we're keeping the situation
under close review
on our europe correspondent michelle
clifford joins us now from brussels
where eu foreign ministers are due to
meet to discuss
the situation hi michelle um so meeting
again today there's been a lot of
talking going on
a lot of talking but it's clear that the
negotiations the meetings that occurred
last week with the last one on friday in
geneva um between the foreign minister
of russia sergey lavrov and anthony
blinken the secret u.s secretary of
state did not make the progress that
people were hoping for so the efforts to
try and
de-escalate around the border with
ukraine continue as you mentioned eu
foreign ministers are going to be
meeting in brussels today anthony
blinken will call into that meeting uh
remotely and
there will be tensions at that meeting
because there isn't unanimity among eu
members about what should happen and
there's going to be particular pressure
i think on the germans some member
states want the germans to exert
leverage on russia by stopping uh the
nordstrom 2 pipeline bringing gas from
russia to germany and western europe
it's something that the germans feel
uncomfortable about because of the gas
price situation at the moment but that
clearly will be a big focus now the uk
foreign secretary list trust is also
going to be in brussels today she will
be meeting the nato secretary general
this afternoon but she's actually
wearing two hats today
okay she has taken over from lord frost
as the brexit negotiator and she will be
meeting her counterpart at the european
commission trying to edge forward on
that very thorny issue still of the
northern ireland protocol okay michelle
thank you
more than 200 people have been killed
after islamic state fighters stormed a
syrian prison sparking a battle which is
now going on into a fifth day our middle
east correspondent aleister bunkel has
the latest
there are two sort of elements of
islamic state that are holding out at
the moment one is a pocket that remains
within a section of the prison they're
still holding that despite uh facing
an onslaught from syrian democratic
forces supported by
u.s forces as well who are in syria both
on the ground and in the air so you
still got that element within the prison
itself
and then you've got a secondary element
and those are made up of the prisoners
who escaped on thursday during the
initial attack and they have fled out
into the surrounding countryside
a lot of them are hiding in houses and
they are taking the fight back uh to the
syrian democratic forces as well there
was one occasion uh when they encircled
them and they tried to um attack them
from outside the prison
uh if you like so this is really violent
uh stuff hundreds dead mainly uh the
security forces and the is prisoners
quite a lot of civilians as well many of
the civilians we're hearing from our
producers in
that part of syria have started fleeing
the area because they're worried about
being used either as civilian human
shields or they're just worried about
being caught up in the fighting so a lot
of them are now seeking refuge either
with relatives or some in mosques as
well
the very worrying thing about this is
that it is the largest attack of its
kind by islamic state since it lost its
self-declared caliphate
and it would also seem to suggest uh
major intelligence failings by the
coalition and by the kurdish syrian
forces
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now on the program a
man has pleaded guilty to the abduction
of a four-year-old girl from her
family's camping tent in western
australia last year cleo smith was found
alone in a house by police 18 days after
she was taken
terence daryl kelly faces up to 20 years
in prison and will appear in court in
march
today's guilty plea is confirmation of
the excellent policing work and just how
strong a case had been presented by
western australian police force and i'd
just like to place on the record again
my admiration respect and thanks to the
western australian police force for the
way they handled the clio case it's been
extraordinary that's confirmation they
did an outstanding job
british man who died in thailand
following an alleged assault has been
named as marcus evans from western
supermarket thai police have arrested a
22 year old man and recovered a sickle
which is believed to have been the
murder weapon
aid is continuing to arrive on the
remote island nation of tonga after
large parts were devastated by an
underwater volcano eruption and the
tsunami which followed naval ships from
australia new zealand the uk and japan
have successfully delivered vital
supplies despite tonga's strict covert
19 border policy
a senior taliban spokesperson has told
sky news the international community has
a moral obligation to recognize the new
government in afghanistan
he defended the new regime and says his
administration has a lot of respect for
women
but speaking to women and girls in kabul
our special correspondent alex crawford
was told of a very different reality
the taliban are increasingly intolerant
of women's protests about their rights
the latest a week ago was broken up by
fighters using pepper spray
and they didn't stop there
we've spoken to multiple witnesses who
saw the taliban raiding several homes
including this one rounding up the
female organizers
she managed to post this video as the
taliban came looking for her
help me the taliban are here she's
crying
she and her three sisters were taken
away by armed men witnesses told us they
looked like taliban special forces the
girls haven't been seen since
others have also been targeted
we got a rare interview with one of the
taliban's most senior spokesman he's
part of the delegation to norway this
week that'll urge the world to lift
sanctions and he insisted the taliban
valued women we have a lot of respect
for women we do not threaten women ever
can i show you um a video of a young we
pull up tamanna's video with her
desperate cries for help
yes yeah i've seen it i've seen they're
quite well known in afghanistan right
now that video is uh of course
distressing the ministry of interior
absolutely rejected it and called the
video fake uh it was how is that fake
if it's fake where is the
approach the ministry of interior and
ask them how how they can came to that
conclusion
but we got no reply from the ministry
alex crawford sky news kabul
and you can watch alex's report from
kebal in full throughout the day here on
sky news and also on our mobile app
looking at the latest coronavirus data
for you in the uk talking to world
health organization shortly 75 000 new
cases of covered 19 reported
75 more people have died within 28 days
of a positive test bringing that number
total ukgs 153
862.
bosses of the country's largest airlines
have written to the government demanding
restriction-free travel for those who
are fully vaccinated the government is
due to review the rules for england next
week
trusts in england lost almost 2 million
days in staff absences due to long covet
in the first 18 months of the pandemic
mps are calling for compensation for
workers and for long covey to be
recognised as an occupational disease
secondary schools in england will each
receive a thousand pounds to help
support the covert vaccination program
the department for education says
special schools will be given additional
cash based on pupil numbers
the iconic french fashion designer
tierra moogley who dressed beyonce and
lady gaga has died at the age of just 73
the iconic french fashion designer
um here he is uh on the catwalk uh with
some of the models the announcement
was made on his instagram account he
also designed clothes for davey bowie
cindy crawford and sharon stone
the singer diana ross tweeted a picture
of the two of them together writing i
will miss you tierra mugler this was a
wonderful time in our lives
quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days staying largely dry is
rather overcast but northern scotland
will have some rain most places will
start cloudy and frost free but rain
will affect the far north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
some cool pictures for you know very
cool pictures from greece uh when you
think of greece you think about sandy
beaches and baking sunshine don't they
they all come to mind but take a look at
this from
mykonos
polar jet streamers hit southern greece
leaving the island with rare snowfall
and temperatures of minus 10 degrees
schools near the capital athens have
been shot today and tomorrow with parts
of the nearby island of evia without
security so that's just one of the
images that we've got for you uh on the
programme this morning what else have we
got have a quick look at this
here we go
here we go this is the
metro great barrier teeth the metro has
this shot of a pet fish whose teeth grew
so long that she
she couldn't eat uh the five-year-old
porcupine puffer fish goldie received a
life-saving emergency operation where
her teeth were
cut in half that's quite a smile isn't
it there you go
the mirror has this picture of a
building conservationist saving
wakefield cathedral spire from
247 feet
up in the air it makes me giddy just
looking at it the restoration works on
the 500 year old spire are costing
nearly 45
000
pounds brave person
and the eye newspaper carries a picture
of a flying car which has been deemed er
with by the slovak transport authority
there it is it's successfully completed
more than 200 takeoffs and landings and
can reach speeds of up to 118 miles an
hour but don't rush it once the vehicle
can only carry two people at this stage
bang bang chitty chitty bang bang you
have to be of a certain age i suppose do
you know who wrote that cheeseburger do
you do
are you going to guess no you're not
going to guess ian fleming
yes he did i know and inside the times
is a picture from the federation of
international sports table football
open tournament in suffolk with a player
eyeing up his next move again everybody
our top stories for you so far this
morning the united states has ordered
the families of all embassy staff in
kiev to leave ukraine amid heightened
fears of a russian invasion
more than 200 people have been killed
after islamic state fighters stormed a
syrian prison sparking a battle which is
now going on into a fifth day
and the prime minister has asked the
cabinet office to investigate
allegations of islamophobia by a muslim
tory mp
within the last half hour the education
secretary nadim zahawi has told me the
claims made by nusrat ghani are painful
and must be investigated
this is a serious
uh allegation it you know it takes
someone a lot to
make such a a a claim i think it's a
point that um
has allowed
uh the ability to put her
case forward put the evidence forward to
the cabinet office
tamara's here with this um my goodness
me just when he thought it can't get any
worse it just has yes and downey street
have been incredibly quick to try and
close this down we got a message from
them at seven o'clock on the dot of
seven o'clock saying the prime minister
has asked the cabinet office to
investigate nus ghani's very serious
allegations she said that when she
raised this with the prime minister two
years almost two years ago
he said i can't do anything about it go
and talk to the conservative party and
they'll do an internal investigation and
she wasn't very happy with that outcome
because she didn't even know if the
people who'd said this about her were
indeed conservatives or exactly how it
had come about
now they've asked the cabinet secretary
to investigate after the prime minister
spoke to her last night we haven't heard
back from her yet but one assumes that
he ran the idea past her and nadim
zahari said he hopes that this
investigation comes back very swiftly i
think what's been interesting about how
this has played out kay obviously in the
most dangerous week for the prime
minister personally that this has come
out is that you've seen two cabinet
ministers nadim zahawi and sajid javid
come out very quickly as soon as she
spoke out in the sunday times and said
this must be investigated fully where
the government's official line is oh we
gave her the chance to um to ask the
conservative party for an inquiry so
downey street have moved very quickly
but it just shows that when the
government is as unstable as it is at
the moment this whole state of waiting
for sue gray little fires start popping
up everywhere and it becomes very
difficult to put them out great idea for
a title for a serious app thanks very
much we'll see you at tomorrow's tech at
nine o'clock thank you
chair of the labour muslim network
abzell khan wrote to the conservative
party chair oliver dowden in october to
demand the government did much more to
protect british muslims uh let's speak
to them now hello to you thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
what are you making about what we've
been reading in the um sunday times and
indeed what a couple of ministers have
been saying to us today
well i've been struggling i suppose for
a number of years and what has been
happening
and in those few years i've written to
almost half a dozen times to different
people
people who have been leading the
executive party different ministers to
the prime minister
and i felt you know they've never taken
it seriously now with most of the
gandhiji situation uh i must say i am
saddened
uh but i'm not surprised in light of the
whole history that we have here
um how do you feel as a muslim today do
you feel that the labour party is more
welcoming i mean they have had their own
criticism as far as allegations of
islamophobia are concerned
okay you're absolutely right they have
and i am the chair of the muslim network
we produced a report
which did highlight that there are
issues within the labor party but what i
must point out is it's actually
not that there isn't a problem in the
society or the labor party or any other
political party the real acting issue
here is the difference
in how the leadership responds to it
when we produce that report the
leadership in the labour party accepted
it and then acted on it and the
difference we have in the conservative
party is that all that having done
similarly has been given which
highlights actually there is far greater
problem in the conservative party but
they are still in state of denial
and that is what is concerning and i
think the reason for that i would say to
you is is all leads from the top because
boris himself
have said things about different
communities which are just not
acceptable including muslim women and
when he made that command of a lateral
box
comparing the muslim woman's two
there was a spike of
375 percent
of this hate against the muslim woman so
i think because of that culture which is
a real issue and i think i welcome the
inquiry that he's done again you can see
how lake he has been he was directly
asked by muslim herself and here we are
two years later that now he's decided to
do that but there's a wider problem in
the conservative party and that requires
i would say a
wider independent inquiry and i think
the quality commission probably should
be now seriously looking at
investigating the conservative party
and should the chief whip um step back
while any investigation is carried out
by the cabinet office
hello uh cabinet office will
do that i just hope that they deal with
this part quickly
but i think the wider issue is the party
as a whole
and that really needs to be looked at
but what do you think should happen to
the chief whip in the meantime
well i mean look it's a matter for him
and the party or the prime minister i
would say uh he need to take assessment
clearly there's a conflict here uh
nusrat is saying that there has been
this discussion and he's totally denying
it now if he feels he can still carry on
it's a matter for him i mean if i was in
his shoes i would step back
okay good to talk to you thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
uh joining us now dominic grieve former
attorney general for england and wales
hello to you thanks for joining us on
the program
how has your former party found itself
in this position
because it's
taken the view that as it doesn't as
it's been open to muslims to come in at
the highest levels
it has failed to note the existence of
islamophobia at other levels of the
party
and i chaired a commission for citizens
uk in 2017 on muslim participation in
public life
and
what the deterrence were to muslims
participating in public life
and i have absolutely no doubt from that
commission that islamophobia was one of
the reasons why many muslims didn't feel
able to step up and do more within the
wider community
and it's a serious problem and i think
the comment that was just made
about boris johnson's
uh mockery of muslim women
is
is was a very telling example indeed at
the time he did it
i remember saying that i hope very much
he would never become leader of the
conservative party because i would be
leaving it
uh and i think that's turned out to be
fairly pressured actually
given what he said about muslim women
which you know but by any measure was
despicable
how difficult um can it be for women um
like the former minister junior minister
going to see him to say this has
happened to me and then her being
she says dismissed
it's very difficult for me to to make a
judgment on that
my experience when i was in parliament
was that uh muslims in the parliament
parliamentary party were welcomed
and indeed nusrat was a very valued
colleague so what exactly went on around
this uh episode in which she was she
lost office uh very very difficult to to
make a judgment and i would be reluctant
to do so
but i do understand very clearly
her concerns uh about feeling
marginalized because she was a muslim
woman who was expressing i think this
was the key thing she was expressing her
muslimness i think that is the issue
um
question
which whether she was in fact explaining
that she had muslim beliefs
and values which might have been
variants with other people
yeah i mean what does it even mean
muslimness i don't know um as far as i
think well i think i can answer that
question up to a point it's a difficult
question to answer but i think it's
about whether it applies also to people
of other faiths
it's it's about whether in your life you
are expressing your faith in the way you
are conducting yourself
and i think that's how i would interpret
it
and where how i would interpret the
problem that she may have had
i'm more reasonable
should embrace all of that shouldn't we
well of course we should because we live
in a pluralist society
there are people from many faiths and
none in our background and we have to be
tolerant and accepting and also
look at the contributions which people
can make in our wider society and if
we're to prosper for the future that is
absolutely essential
i just want to ask you what was going on
with uh sue gray um and we believe that
she's speaking to dominic cummings um
today one wonders why um we cherry pick
on what we believe from the dominic
cummings sometimes we believe him
sometimes we don't do you believe what
he's been saying about the parties
i would always take anything that mr
cummings says with a pinch of salt
because after all i've been the
recipient of smear campaigns which came
out of number 10 downing street where mr
cummings was
in charge of the operation
uh so i'm always dubious about what he
has to say but it's clear he also has a
desire of vengeance against mr johnson
uh and as a result he's spilling the
beans on things which he saw as taking
place within number 10 downing street
which he thought were unacceptable
so it's not so much what he has to say
it's the corroborating evidence which
seems to me to be the key in all this
and on the question of parties in number
10 it's abundantly clear that he was
right about that because parties did
take place in number 10 downing street
despite the prime minister's earlier
denials that any such thing had happened
it does look as though the prime
minister is literally hanging on by his
fingertips but you know he is the
comeback king if it's not him then who
would you like to support as prime
minister of the conservative party going
forward
i don't think i have a view because i'm
not in the house of commerce you do
you do
i would like to see somebody who brings
back what i would describe as pragmatic
an ideological conservatism that doesn't
mean to say you don't do some quite
radical things but you look at
what the interests of the united kingdom
are and you provide leadership
where you can show integrity
if there is no integrity in leadership
then the ability ultimately of leaders
to lead in taking difficult decisions
becomes very difficult mrs thatcher had
integrity she took radical decisions
which people disagreed with but she was
able to provide that leadership the
present prime minister cannot provide
that leadership because he is admired
in his own dishonesty
and that really does prime minister
anything else we need a muslim prime
minister what do you think
i i don't think the question of whether
we have a muslim prime minister or not
is really relevant that many muslims
have great integrity many christians
have great integrity many people many
people with no religious faith have
integrity uh so as far as i'm concerned
i would like to see the conservative
party under the leadership of somebody
who are i know i can respect and trust
and there are plenty of such people
around it will be a great pleasure for
me to be able to start supporting the
conservative party again when such a
person arrives okay i'll be more obvious
maybe somebody i don't know maybe
somebody like rishi sunak or perhaps
nadeem zahawi or perhaps sadie javid
all those people are potential
candidates it seems to me for the
leadership of the party and all of them
it's not just a single pebble on the
beach might well be able to do the job
very well there are also some people who
are not in cabinets at all
who might be very good at leading the
conservative party and leading the
country so that's why i'm not
prescriptive on this what i am quite
clear about in my own mind is that the
present
incumbent of downing street mr johnson
is completely unfit for office and the
question this week is are conservative
mps going to have the courage
to stand up for the values which i think
most of them have and say time's up
okay good to talk to you thank you so
much for taking the time thank you
hello again everybody covered
restrictions are easing across the uk
this week and it seems the world health
organization is cautiously optimistic
that the virus could be on its way out
in europe let's talk about it
with dr david nabarro hi uh doctor it's
good to talk to you
is the end in sight in europe for covert
oh can't hear you at the moment doctor
are you muted at all
uh thank you very much there we go
the end is in sight
but
how long is it going to take to get
there
and what sort of difficulties will we
face on the way
those are the questions that none of us
can answer because this virus continues
to give us
challenges and surprises so i do want
everybody everybody who's watching this
morning to your great program
to do one thing and that is to go on
treating this virus with respect it's
not changed
it's absolutely not suddenly become
uh a soft thing
it is still very serious and so for me
if the end is in sight that's good news
but it's as though we're just passing
the halfway mark on a marathon and we
can see that yes there is an end and the
fast runners are getting through ahead
of us but we've still got a long long
way to trench and it's going to be tough
as far as our own health secretary is
concerned sajid javid says that we need
to treat kovid like we treat the flu do
you agree
oh well
i mean again i keep
wondering what the people who make these
amazing predictions
know
that i and my colleagues in the world
health organization don't know
you see what people are seeing from
around the world and reporting to the wh
show
is this is still a very very dangerous
virus especially for people who've not
been vaccinated
and who've not been exposed to it before
it also can mutate and form variants and
we've seen several but we know there are
more not far away
so quite honestly
we are not saying that this should be
considered to be like flu or indeed like
anything else it's a new virus and we
must go on treating it as though it is
full of surprises very nasty and rather
cunning
and what do you make of the suggestions
uh by our prime minister that most of
the restrictions that have been in place
under plan b should be lifted uh by next
week
well restrictions are put in place by
governments
in order to help people
make the choices that will keep them
healthy
they're not put there
to
[Music]
work against what people need to do
after all the virus is the problem and
people are the solution but people need
governments to help them
now governments have to be consistent
and clear and not be shifting their
position
and all governments everywhere
should not suggest to people that the
data have suddenly changed or the
viruses suddenly got
incredibly weak no
governments have got to set the
direction and not shy away from that
so all i'm asking every leader in the
world to do
is to help everybody stay focused on the
job which is keeping this virus at bay
preventing people from getting infected
if at all possible and making certain
that we are well prepared to deal with
further surges as they come
okay good to talk to you as always i
hope the grandchildren are well thank
you very much for joining us thank you
very much great i'm glad to hear it
thank you
i want to show you these pictures have a
look at world record uh sets at an ice
hockey match i love this in pennsylvania
they lob all the teddy bears
onto the ring they do this uh because
all of these teddy bears uh go to uh
homeless children or children that are
living in shelters the hershey bears
team held their annual teddy bear toss
to raise money for the charity and this
time collected 52
341 bears and stuffed animals smashing
their previous world record that great
big teddy bear lobbing it over the top
money raise will go to youth and
disability charities as well in the
state which is absolutely fantastic